i'm halal mahidin doha with the top
stories on al jazeera
buildings in gaza housing media outlets
including
al jazeera media network and the
associated press
have been evacuated following a warning
from the israeli military
journalists had to leave their offices
after being told the building
will be targeted in one hour
this is the building that has been
threatened
well israel's ambulance service says one
person has died
and one person has been badly wounded in
tel aviv after
30 rockets were fired from gaza one of
them fell in the middle of a street
nearby buildings were damaged by the
shrapnel one of the rockets
hit ben-gurion international airport
protests are underway in the palestinian
territory as
israel continues to bombard gaza from
the air and the ground
crowns have gathered in alberta in the
occupied west bank where anger over past
and present injustices
has been building near ibrahim has more
from albire
in the occupied west bank many
palestinians have been telling
us over the past days that they are
protesting because they believe
that the nakba is still ongoing it's not
just an incident that happened 73 years
ago
but that all of what happened or most of
what's hap what happened
in in 1948 is still ongoing now
when it comes to palestinians lives
under occupation the land grabs
the expansion of illegal israeli
settlements the
subtler attacks that are intensifying
against palestinians
the house evictions so you name it so
for many palestinians this they not just
remind them
of what happened 73 years ago but it's
it's
it could it reminds them that they are
still
living under these circumstances this is
why
many protesters are taking to the
streets of different cities in the
occupied west bank we're seeing
less numbers than we've seen on friday
protests
but the day is still young and we might
be seeing more and more
protests across different cities in the
west bank
three funerals have been held already
this morning for
palestinians who were shot dead by the
israeli army's fire in confrontations on
friday and there are the number of
palestinians who were
killed uh on in friday was 11
and one of those palestinians the
israeli army said that he tried to carry
out an attack against the israeli army
near an illegal israeli settlement and
they didn't hand his body over to his
family for burial
this is not something new this is a
policy that israel implements by
withholding the bodies of palestinians
it believes we're
involved in attacks against its soldiers
or settlers
and it keeps those bodies to kind of
punish the families and so they can't
bury their loved ones
so this is the situation that many
palestinians would tell you
it's frustrating they're also frustrated
at the palestinian authority
they say that it hasn't been giving a
strong reaction when it comes to
helping them fight the israeli
occupation and many
here have been telling us that if the
palestinian authority is not
part of the solution then it is part of
the problem
uh well let's get more now from al
jazeera suffolk al kahoot he joins us
live
from gaza stuff what you normally work
in the building that we're showing our
viewers
uh on this live shot from gaza uh just
give us a sense now of where you are
and what has happened in the previous
hours or so
well let's start with uh the phone call
that one of the residents
uh living in this in the in
building where al jazeera is staying or
taking the roof of this building
for uh for the the cavalry uh one of the
residents received the phone call
he said that it was from the israeli
army uh warning him to leave
and to tell others to leave the building
because they want to bombard it so uh
the gentleman he
uh started either calling or uh
attacking others who living for work in
the building
to evacuate he said that the israelis
told them you have one hour
to leave and inform others to leave the
building
immediately uh all of al jazeera arabic
and al jazeera english
that the teens they they started to
collect as
much as they could from the personal and
uh the equipment of the office
especially the cameras and other uh
important things that
use for immediate coverage so all of us
my colleagues they rushed out the
building
and uh we we informed of course uh
our other colleagues uh not to come
those who were supposed to come
to the office so now we are all staying
outside the buildings
lots of international media now are
surrounding this building angela all the
cameras all the
many sngs outside uh just to
provide clean feed as they said for
the destruction of the building in case
the israelis apply
uh you know the threat or the warning
uh so far we can say this building is 11
floor
building uh most of it or half of it is
residential
and the other half is the private sector
offices including
lawyers and private companies and other
private sector
facilities uh the al jazeera and
associated press
uh we both both we rent at the top of
this building
we are dividing the rufus building and
uh
you know al jazeera and the ap could be
seen from the top from everywhere
with cameras with coverage as under the
sun as we say
now we are covering from the street
until we
manage or try to find alternative or
find a plan b for our
coverage absolutely and it's interesting
you you mentioned their software that
uh there are professional companies in
in one half of this
11-story tower block not least al
jazeera and the associated press
but half of that building is residential
will those
residents in the tower also have been
given
a warning to evacuator is there a risk
that people could still be in that
building
look there are two ways of israeli
warning
either they uh send a
small rocket as we call it knocking
rocket by the israelis drones
they hit the top of the building of uh
of the aimed building then all the
people understand that this is a warning
and they have to leave
because the israelis are going to bomb
it and the second way is that
they have they call one person of the
whole building
could be the guard could be anyone
living or working in this building
so one this one or that have been
informed to tell the others
he is in charge of informing the rest of
the people
or residents who live or work in this
building
this is the only two ways that the
israelis are normally
informed or warned the palestinians
to evacuate their buildings and to leave
the residential facilities or offices
um you mentioned stafford about how
difficult it is uh certainly for a media
organization there's a lot of equipment
we
need to tell stories to get the the
story out to the world but
but for others who are in there if
you're living in that apartment
that's your entire life in that
apartment just give us a sense of
how difficult it is for people living in
the gaza strip when they are given a
one-hour warning
what do people pack up what's important
to residents when they're told your
building will be destroyed in one hour
how do they prioritize what to pack up
and what to leave behind
that's a complicated question because
the answer is also complicated because
you know
this reminds us or recalled the
experience of hanaldi building and
another two
high residential buildings that include
uh from 10 to 14 residential floors so
you suddenly uh receive a warning that
you have few minutes to leave
uh it's not something that in the other
people
are they have to leave apartment b or
plan b
or building b that they can immediately
just switch or turn on on their cars and
move
many people they start first of all 51st
they
evacuate uh they try to get the
important dichromates like password etc
or money if they have
and then they wait outside to see if
this
warning is true or maybe or
the israelis are going to change their
minds etcetera etcetera
once the building is destroyed then the
people who live there or work they
realize that this is the end of
uh of their house or of their uh
residential facility
so in india the social structure
structure is very solid and concrete
people
they uh normally especially in the
during escalation
they help each other uh no one
closed his door for for someone or in
front of someone who lost his house
so um lots of people they uh they
announce or they tell or they start
maybe visiting the destroyed places they
ask others to
to hospitalize them and they're bound
until they find solutions
some others they go to their relatives
the brothers etc
if some others they have some money of
course they go and
or try to rent apartment or or find
a mediatek solution for the family
especially when
if they have kids but there is nothing
that we say we can't say that everybody
has plan b
because he lived in gaza and he's
expecting that uh his house could be
anytime destroyed or we will receive he
will receive a warning from the israelis
that
this is the israeli army we are going to
bomb this is something
uh not practical for the palestinians to
find alternatives
alternative the solutions just
let me remind recall the experience of
al-jazeera also in the world 2014
when the israelis also they fired a
warming uh
a live fire on our office uh it was in
the morning i still remember that day
uh in the middle of the coverage in the
middle of uh
preparing for the the daily covering
suddenly
uh from the borderline the israelis
uh uh live fire
one bullet i still remember that on on
directly
to in into or inside our office
so we rushed we understood that was a
message we have not received at that
time any warning from anyone to leave
but that was um you know a message
uh to leave or
[Music]
we thought about is that the office this
is a warning and we have to leave
that was uh the first experience was
uh with the israeli army warnings uh for
al jazeera
and today is the second time now we are
uh all leaving
uh it is still early uh to look for and
to prepare ourselves for
uh the heavy covering that we are we
have been doing beyond night
of course we have plan b uh but still
early
uh to fix everything because we had to
leave everything behind us in the office
especially the sng
and the live equipment coverage yes
it's uh it's certainly not not our first
oh
we're going to stay with you so what it
looks like
yes it looks like there has been a
strike targeting
the building targeting the al
jala building for viewers just joining
us we're bringing you a live
shot from gaza at suffolk alcahoot
still on the phone i hope you're safe
suffolk the al jazeera team has managed
to evacuate from
that building they were given one hour's
notice that the israeli military
were intending to attack this
11 story building half of that building
is residential offices the other half of
that building
is private enterprises lawyers and so on
al jazeera's offices in gaza are housed
in that building which has now been
struck
by a missile we assumed by the israeli
military the associated press
offices are also in that
building bringing you this live shot
here now suffolk are you still
on the phone can you still hear us
yes yes i come here okay i'm glad to
hear that you're safe and well uh
can what can you see from your position
how far away
are you from that building that has now
just been bombed well most uh
let's say a lot of people have been
gathering
in the in this area our building is
located
in the heart of java city uh
and it's easy uh to reach the office
from all the directions
next to our office there were lots of
buildings on facilities that had been
destroyed and people i myself have been
receiving lots of phone calls
and lots of uh either whatsapp or
facebook from friends colleagues even
relatives abroad asking me what happened
is that true and you know checking with
me
uh just to check so far just to change
a lot of people are gathering near our
office
lots of media journalists cameramen uh
uh civil defense card or vehicles are
also standing by
so just to jump in lots of people
and media uh colleagues are
standing by and waiting there to see if
the israelis are going to apply and
destroy it or not
okay so can you just do we know at this
stage whether that was
a warning shot that we've just been uh
showing our viewers
or if that is the main strike because
the buildings that uh the
this uh these live pictures that we're
focusing on now
uh we can still see sir sumerians
the warning shot was in 2014. i was
talking about the experience we're
talking
the warning is not for al jazeera itself
directly
we have not we were not the one who
received the warning from the israelis
it was one of the residents living in
this in the building
received the warning and in his turn he
informed
and he was in charge of informing the
others who
are who live in this building okay just
to jump in on top there
now we have seen it that we believe that
is now
the strike that was now the strike
on the al jala building
as you can see from the live pictures
we're showing you now that appears to be
a direct
hit in the side of the building lots
of uh smoke billowing out of there
as we're hearing from our colleague
asafoetz
al kahlut when the building was targeted
uh in 2014 uh the the warning
there was no warning shots uh there were
a couple of bullets shot through the
glass giving people notice they needed
to get out
on this occasion a residence in the
tower
someone in the tower the terrorist owner
was given notification
that the israeli military were intending
to strike
then all residents of that tower were
given one hour to get
out we saw a smaller explosion on those
pictures
a much bigger explosion there lots
of smoke and dust arising outside of
that building
not sure if it will stay standing or not
we're going to keep
our eyes closely trained on this
uh but certainly for more context that
building
is where al jazeera's offices are there
we are another strike
on that tower and the terror has come
down
that is the al-jala tower
that tower is where al jazeera's offices
are warehoused the associated press
offices were also housed in that
building whenever you see
journalists doing live updates from gaza
they're usually standing on the roof of
that building which has
now been flattened in an airstrike
by the israeli military
so that is a landmark an institution
that has now been raised
to the ground in gaza
important to remember as well that in
this building
in addition to the media offices of al
jazeera
and the associated press there are
professional offices in that building
and half of that 11 story terror block
is also residential properties
where families have been living
their homes have now been
destroyed
let's head back now to uh suffolk
alcahlutz
are you still on the phone can you still
hear us uh yeah yeah i'm just watching
you know that
which was al jazeera building or angela
building
lots of dust lots of destruction how
does that make you feel suffering this
was your place of work how does this
make you feel
watching that building come crashing
down
you know i've been working in this
building
for 11 years now and you know
i have been covering uh
let's say lots of events uh from this
building we have good memories with our
colleagues
we have lived lots of events personal
professional
uh experiences with about our colleagues
you know
uh now everything in two seconds just
vanished so
it's a very difficult day um i'm also
going to let our viewers know as well as
that building came crashing down
the there was real distress in this
newsroom here in doha
as we watch that building come down now
now
you know one can understand the feeling
of the people who
uh who whose homes uh have been
destroyed by
by such kind of aircraft air force or
air attack
so uh it's really difficult to wake up
one day
and then uh you realize that your
office is not there with all
that the career the experience the
memories that you
uh you had with in the last 10 or 11
years
yes certainly the the the stories that
have been told
from this building the uh
is it's very difficult to to express
what a loss
this is uh but certainly not just for al
jazeera for the associated press and for
for others who are
using this building in this facility to
get the stories
of gaza to get the stories of this
region
uh out to a wider offices uh
it it's really it's really quite
staggering to see that um
an iris warning was given to get people
out
we're showing our viewers now uh the the
moment that
i think that was the third bomb strike
that managed to bring
down the al-jala tower
but it's so it's a very different
skyline
in gaza a very different skyline for
from here on in
and it's going to be a very different
experience as well because it makes
certainly the job of telling these
stories much harder when you
destroy the offices of journalists who
are trying to get
people's voice and people's experience
out to the outside world
uh he we think we may have lost our
our phone link with that that's al
jazeera's uh suffolk al cahludz
uh who has been working from that tower
uh safwad are you still with us can you
hear us
i am i am are you with other colleagues
other people who've been evacuated from
the building we understand that you're
all trying to congregate safely
somewhere
away from the the building which has now
been destroyed
how are other people reacting to this
let me just before that maybe
something really very impressive
all of my colleagues are despite the
sadness
and all that we just mentioned before
they didn't stop a second they were
looking for
alternative and
uh you know
just to keep al jazeera on on top of the
news
uh my colleague
and of course my uh our cameraman
and also the assistant of the sng they
have from the same second they
asked me let's work and try to apply
plan b so apart from their personal
safety that immediately they evacuated
they they started to think of the
how to keep al jazeera on how to keep
our coverage on again on top of the news
so
i really uh have no words were to
express
uh my appreciation
yes and all the good the good manners
for
these uh for these teams in gathering
you know i i have been working before i
did with many teams with
many uh media groups but uh
really these that my colleagues here are
the best
that i've ever worked with they don't
think about their personal life
then about the the professional one
and the the coverage of al jazeera
they want to keep it on so uh
despite his personal uh problems
uh at home and this offering would have
fun
i'm sorry to say that online about uh
this is one of the stories that we can
tell about but
he immediately asked me let's find or
let's apply
plan b i i from the beginning i told him
let's think about your
our personal safety and then we will sit
lambie don't worry uh
there's always a plan b so um
my colleagues uh are really amazing
colleagues
we are family of al jazeera in gaza uh
all together
ega and ege al jazeera network
all of them they are one hand one spirit
one practical team they certainly
are uh suffolk
joining us there live from gaza it's a
difficult job you do at the best of
times
southwards it's exceptionally difficult
now
that your office your place of work has
now been bombed
in front of us live on television we are
grateful to everything
you and the rest of our colleagues are
doing
to keep telling those stories this
channel
will not be silenced
al jazeera will not be silenced we can
guarantee you that right now
joining us live from gaza thank you very
much indeed and stay
safe let's turn now to our colleague
harry fawcett
he's in west jerusalem harry you've been
uh
covering the violence uh
within israel uh we're seeing these
devastating strikes we're also seeing
the al jazeera offices being bombed
live on television
what what reaction do you have first of
all
well yeah just just to firstly i mean i
mean occupying excuse me here in
shakhtar where a lot of what we're
seeing now from gaza
uh really began the tensions in
jerusalem
um i i'm not able to see the images from
here but uh but thanks to your and
sakurai's exceptional work
i'm pretty clear uh what has just
happened
it is one of those rare instances where
uh as dispassionate and as out of the
story you try and keep yourself this is
this is a very personal moment for all
of us as it is
a major major story in this developing
situation i'm just thinking back to
the first time i went in there and met
safwat
and uh he offered me a cup of tea and
said sugar i said no
and he happily said okay just a little
bit and put two massive spoonfuls of
sugar in
a very delicious cup of tea and that was
the start of our relationship that was
the start of my time
working in gaza and the
idea that that place is now no more is
really quite
extraordinary to contemplate um you know
the
the uh live position with those amazing
uh dusk views out over gaza
the kitchen where we used to sit around
have meals
watch the big screen uh the room where
people used to
sleep because it's uh often a 24 7
business especially in gaza
the area where people used to pray
it's all just gone and and hearing
suspects describe it
uh quite so well and his emotions must
be running high
uh it really is a testament to his
professionalism and that of the rest of
the team
in gaza it
in occupied east jerusalem thank you for
the clarification there
this is of course uh where
uh a lot of the recent escalation
comes comes comes back to certainly you
could
people will argue for for for years and
millennia over when this violence
actually started
but certainly in shikhtara this could be
where
this most recent round of escalation
between the israelis and the
palestinians
it has its origins what's happening
right now where
you are right now it is uh
kind of a strange one of those strange
moments when
what you're looking at is in entire
contrast to what you're listening to i'm
looking at a
a group of young activists uh student
age
mainly mainly female with a few uh a few
labs as well they are painting
uh a message on the whitewashed wall of
one of the properties that is at risk of
having its palestinian
owners displaced and so they are here in
the sunshine in dappled sunshine
in this place where there has been
itself obviously a lot of violence isn't
it
as recently as this morning there were
some pretty severe crashes here and
yesterday
friday there was a shooting uh with a
face-off between
uh jewish settlers two of whom at least
were armed
and a group of palestinians who were
firing rockets
uh of you know i mean firework rockets
uh into their uh
woodyard and stones and the like uh so
this
remains a tenth place it remains as you
say one of the main
fueling factors of this
uh entire escalation because it's been
going on since the beginning of
ramadan but right now it is
it is peaceful people are looking pretty
cheerful
uh and they're they're painting these
messages on this white rust rule
which is interesting you see this
contrast really because uh
this is a a tale of of two worlds
in a sense if you like on one hand you
have
palestinians uh undergoing daily bombing
we've just seen the al jazeera officers
being bombed live on television on the
other hand
another section of the population in
this very small country
gets to live in peace and security now
that peace and security in tel aviv was
ruptured
uh not more than an hour ago
there has been developments there uh
hamas have
fired rockets into tel aviv uh do we
know
more about this rocket attack because
from following this recent conflict
we understand there will be a
retaliation to the fact that rockets
have made it into tel aviv and killed at
least one person
well yes this is another substantial
barrage
from hamas it has said that it can
sustain
attacks on tel aviv for the next six
months uh should it wish to
uh the certainly that the reporting that
was there this morning
that uh the israeli military had
dealt a very major blow to hamas's
ability to fire rockets
uh obviously the uh fighting factions
inside gaza are trying to answer that
and it does seem that in some extent
they have done so with the
the very sad news of another death
inside tel aviv i mean
obviously people on the israeli side of
this conflict
would disagree with the idea that they
are currently living
in security especially in the areas
around gaza
there is a great deal of insecurity and
they feel often that they've been
uh abandoned to that and that it only
becomes a major issue when
major connotations in the middle of the
country such as tel aviv and the
suburbs around it and the uh city of
like ashkelon and of course the airport
itself
in between jerusalem and tel aviv are
all targeted but
but yes i mean there is of course a huge
disparity in the kind of
power and just the numbers
of those who've been killed and injured
and the kind of
really destructive devastation that we
are witnessing and the most
recent and most uh
sort of difficult to see for someone
who's been in that building so many
times
and works for this organization uh is
the destruction of that
building inside guards in the last few
minutes what kind of impact is all this
going to have
certainly we where you are harry you're
inside
occupied east jerusalem when you see
these kind of images when people who
live there
be the uh palestinian israelis or be the
israeli jews when they see these images
of either the disparity in terms of who
is being
affected by the violence or indeed the
violence itself
how is that being felt by people within
the country
and how is that manifesting
well i i think it's it's manifesting in
many different ways
among different communities and of
course between
individuals but uh as far as hamas is
concerned the
outburst of violence in the west bank is
very much a response to what has been
happening inside gaza
i can tell you when those first rocket
attacks were launched by hamas
towards jerusalem on on monday evening
the first thing
that we noticed was a big round of
cheering inside the damascus gate
steps when the sirens went off
sustained when the explosions were heard
so obviously
for some support among at least some for
the idea of
those attacks uh others
you know there have been instances of
both communities helping each other out
during the uh the aftermath of these
attacks uh even as there is all this
racial violence rolling through the
streets uh as far as israeli jews are
concerned there are some who are
expressing exactly the same
uh kind of concerns that uh that we've
been hearing about the uh
the nature of the destructive power and
from both
the impact of it on the people of gaza
and indeed
the the impact of it in terms of
israel's standing in the world
there are others who say that hamas has
gone too far
that it has got away with too many of
these rounds of escalations
and i was talking to one man down south
where we were near the
gaza border the other day who just
gestured with his hand in a kind of a
flat
cutting motion saying the israeli
military needed to finish it and this
wasn't
someone who immediately came across as
some sort of
rabid racist uh person he was a friendly
uh and generous seeming person who at
the same time
felt it uh possible to say just finish
it making this motion that suggested he
wanted to see
the entire place flattened so it's you
know it is one of these
uh very difficult to encapsulate ideas
how people
feel about this it is a very very
complicated complex set of relationships
and uh and emotions and political
positions um that you will you will hear
different things from different people
sometimes surprising things from people
that you might assume to think something
else from either
other community as you talk to people
around here as you do uh
harry you've been covering this region
for many years now
is it different this time does it feel
different to you
or is this part of the same old
cycle of violence
well it suddenly feels different to me
uh because i've only been here since
2017 so i have not been here
during the the major gaza conflicts that
we've seen
in the last decade or more
i have seen a number of these
escalations i i've been in gaza
as well during the uh during the border
protests that we saw in 2018 2019
um but yes it does feel different it
feels different on the
scale of what is happening militarily
uh from israel into gaza and indeed the
sheer volume
uh and concentration of rockets coming
out that is a major
part of this story that there is this
tactic now
to really seriously threaten major urban
areas with these concentrated
sustained bursts of rocket fire and
and yes the destructive power on show
of what is happening from the air to
gaza we were with
uh tanks israeli tanks and artillery
on thursday night when they started that
enormous barrage
into northern gaza which saw hundreds
and hundreds of people
fleeing their homes and families being
killed
in those strikes as well and the
additional factor is this terrible round
of very personal uh very close quarters
racialized violence they've been
erupting around the country
especially in mixed jewish arab towns
but more generally as well
uh even places that are sort of seen as
places of coexistence and
where people do business with each other
into the friendly
regular terms even in these places we've
seen this erupt
and so i think for a lot of people
living outside gaza inside israel
on the jewish side on the palestinian
israeli side
it feels like this is very close to home
uh not just in terms of
the threat coming from from rocket fire
but also
the threat coming from potentially next
door uh it's it's very
keenly felt okay harry foster they're
joining us on the live
the line from chef jara in occupied east
jerusalem
we appreciate it harry thank you very
much indeed
let's uh speak now to nida ibrahim she
is in albire in the occupied west bank
nida as i speak to you we're showing our
viewers
the pictures of the
al-jala terror block which housed
our offices and the offices of the
associated press
being destroyed by israeli missile
fire if you could just start by by
telling me your reaction i mean i know
we're not supposed to be the story here
but
our offices have been destroyed it makes
us part of this story
so as an al jazeera journalist tell me
your reaction
to this attack on that building in gaza
as you say hala we try to tell the story
and not be
part of the story but as palestinian
journalists we find ourselves being
targeted for telling the story
we have lots and lots of palestinian
journalists who were injured by israeli
fire and who would tell you that the
israeli army would intentionally
throw a tear gas canisters or bullets at
the place where we are standing
as journalists to prevent the story from
going out on air and i'm going to do
something out of habit and talk about my
personal experience when
i first went to gaza i'm a palestinian
journalist but i was not
able to access the gaza strip that is
besieged by israel
but i was only able to do that in 2017.
it was exactly this day may 15th
it was the anniversary of nakba and it
was also coinciding with a very
deeply uh um humiliating let's say uh
or offensive movement for palestinians
which is when the trump administration
moved
its embassy from tel aviv to jerusalem
the emotions were very high
it was my first time in the besieged
gaza strip i was able to see things that
palestinians here
in the occupied west bank only see on tv
although they
are one people one nation and i remember
seeing software there at the protest
that palestinians were taken to
the the bordering line with israel and
and i've seen also
stephanie who was reporting live from
there and i was
thinking that i want to be al jazeera
journalists we have teams
that are invested in the story i am
working now with two great
crew members my our producer rania and
our cameraman joseph
who are making sure every day that we
are
up to news we are telling the story
they're very passionate people
and this is why i was longing to be al
jazeera journalists to be able to tell
the people
the stories that they don't hear on
other news agencies because
some sometimes the story of palestine
would be sensitive for
some uh media organizations so they opt
out or they
just show it when it's breaking news
but here in al jazeera we tell this
story every day
of palestinians whose house are being
evicted we've also covered journalists
who
uh there's one journalist we took to
whose eye was blinded by
an israeli bullet and so often times
also we find ourselves telling stories
of journalists who are covering the
story
but generally this is a place that i
i feel proud that i'm a part of and i
feel sad
to see i just looked uh on my mobile
phone now again and again and again
seeing the building being flattened
and it's it's a very sad feeling it is a
a sad feeling
indeed and i can tell our viewers that
when that image
those images were broadcast live to us
on an agency feed of our building being
flattened there were cries of distress
that went out in this newsroom here in
doha
these are certainly our offices that
have been destroyed the associated
press's offices
that have been destroyed in this
airstrike but also
countless palestinian families who lived
in that building
will now be homeless we don't know if
anyone has been
injured in that strike it's important
for our viewers to remember that
gaza is a very densely populated
bit of land very densely populated
buildings packed together as you can see
on your screens
so there is a very real chance that
people could get injured
even though an hour's warning was given
for that building to be evacuated
but nida all of this is happening
on a a very particular day this
uh day of course is a
very important anniversary for
palestinians
uh just tell us more about that
and what's happening where you are on
this day
there are protests that were organized
in different cities
in the occupied west bank to mark this
day and there's a general
strike in the west bank also to remember
nakba to mourn those palestinians who
were killed
in the gaza strip and also here in the
occupied west bank after israel
the israeli forces shot that 11
palestinians on friday as many
protesters here were telling us
on friday that nakba is not just a
memory
nakaba is still ongoing whatever
happened to the palestinians who had to
flee
their lands in 1948 and were never able
to come back to it
palestinians would tell you is the same
thing that israel is trying to do to
palestinians here
to make life so miserable for them that
they have no option but to leave it
the uh eviction of houses in is just one
example the demolition of a
hamsa village in the jordan valley which
we've covered
it was destroyed completely by the
israeli
army with its uh uh the families became
homeless
so there are lots and lots of uh
events and and and daily lives that are
getting ruined by the israeli occupation
and this is why palestinians would tell
you they want to make sure that their
voices heard
now many of them are taking to social
media they they
are saying that they're not the
narrative is changing they're seeing
lots and lots of influencers of
celebrities showing support to
palestinians in shaykh
and they believe those palestinians
we've been speaking to over the past
week
that that the narrative is changing that
they were
able to reach out to more audience and
tell
the palestinian story without censorship
and and that's interesting you raised
that point neither because we
a lot of the there is of course the the
ongoing
war the the violence and the physical
tax but there's the war of the narrative
there's the war over
who controls the narrative which voices
are being heard
who has the sympathy
and solidarity of people of the wider
world
is there a feeling now that
people are now starting to hear the
palestinian side
of the story more in this age of social
media
or do people still feel that their
concerns are not being
taken seriously there's an element of
both scientism
uh whenever these stories are being told
in the wider press
there this there is a sense that
palestinian voices
now have more room to being expressed on
social media
however it's the battle is still ongoing
on
this new battleground that the pilot
this new battleground that the
palestinians
are partaking and it's very dangerous
even to be posting
sometimes we are seeing palestinians who
are posting
on social media that are being detained
in one incident one palestinian was
writing good morning in arabic
and the automatic translation
mistranslated it and the man was thought
by the israeli army that he was going to
be carrying out an attack and he was
arrested
so it's a very tricky situation
specifically for palestinians living
here
they can't share everything they want to
share they can't say everything they
want to say
so there is a lot of focus on
palestinians abroad
to be able to carry that war of
narrative if you may
and also palestinians sorry also
celebrities also influencers also people
who are important and who have the
world's attention
in the past few years the dimension of
palestinians
was kind of restricted in a way of you
have to be showing support for both
sides you have to be feeling empathy for
both sides
now we're seeing more and more people
venture into
no let's wait a minute this is an
occupation we cannot
equate the occupier with the occupied
and we cannot keep talking about this
story as if it's just two sides
getting along together as if it's a
problem a personal problem this is a
political issue
and many palestinians would tell you
that they feel that their voices are
being heard
now there is this also fear of hope
there are people who are
telling you that we're scared to think
that things are changing and then go
back to our reality under occupation
where things are gonna be more of the
same specifically that they are facing a
very strong
israeli propaganda machine we are seeing
also
israelis in the uh world trying to
pressure trying to for example we had uh
organizations that were like airbnb
they decided not to enlist israel legal
israeli settlements in
their app but then under pressure from
israel they
backtracked on that decision so there is
a little bit
of fear of hoping that such things could
change
because the the war is still ongoing
okay nida ibrahim they're joining us
from albir in the occupy
uh in the occupied west bank uh bringing
us all the latest
from your location nida uh
on the knack but thank you very much
indeed we'll of course be crossing back
to our correspondence we're all across
this story for you on al jazeera
but let's take you back now to gaza um
or joining us on the phone
is al jazeera's safwat al kahoot
he is our designated journalist in
gaza and earlier today he was standing
in that building which if you're
watching this on the right of your
screen you will see
the al-jala tower where al jazeera's
offices are based
where the associated press's offices are
based
and where many families palestinian
families used to live
that building was blown up by missile
strike
just around one hour ago southwards you
have now evacuated the building i trust
you've found a place of safety in
gaza just tell us where you are right
now and what what you're seeing
look i have left this area
i mean where uh this
our destroyed office now we are
uh trying to apply plan b we are heading
to
uh get more new equipment to keep our
coverage on
as as you said no silence nobody
know what our market we will continue
the coverage
we are heading now to uh to get
new equipment uh to continue the
coverage despite
the destruction despite losing
everything and leaving everything behind
us
uh you know after the destruction
nothing to see
nothing to get out from the rubble it's
just suddenly everything is rubble
so uh we have no choice but to continue
and the phoenix is waking up again and
looking for new comments
and we will be on air again with with
new equipment with newcomers us and the
new
uh satellite equipment so uh we are now
uh we have secured all of uh
my colleagues and even our colleagues in
al jazeera arabic
they are uh because they are they have
their own
additional sng so now they are they are
doing live coverage from there from the
um i mean next to or in front of
our destroyed house now we are trying to
fix
uh uh our coverage and fix uh the
uh with the new system i mean um
crushing the fingers that we will uh
find a new
uh equipment uh fastly because
the the things are really escalating in
gaza
the the military of hamas has just been
warning from firing
more intensive uh barrages of rockets
towards tel aviv
specifically in response to the
destruction of our
building as they call it where
residential people
safe people were staying so
the coverage should continue and
let me tell you all that we are safe we
are uh taking shelters we are mobilizing
and
moving according to the plan the plan
of the coverage we have al jazeera has
always planned b
plan b plan c all the plans uh but we'll
never stop
uh it is indeed uh suffolk we're very
relieved to hear
that you and all our al jazeera english
and
al jazeera arabic colleagues are safe
and well uh it's important to remind our
viewers that
making television is very resource
intensive it's very resource heavy you
can't just do it on an iphone
there's an awful lot of equipment
necessary in those offices
uh to be able to to put out the
programming that we do
we're grateful to you for joining us on
the phone and to give us that first-hand
testimony on the phone
while we try and enact some kinds of
plan b to be able to get live pictures
and live reporting
out to our global audiences uh but
safford as someone who lives
in gaza you work in gaza you live in
gaza you are
among the people and this is not this is
not your first
rodeo show we say this is not the first
war on gaza that you have lived through
just from a personal perspective tell
our viewers what it's like
what it's like being in gaza
when the territory is under attack like
this
as you said we are used to such kind of
escalation this is not the first or
second or even third time
in the last in the past 20 years since
the beginning of
the empty father we have been living
under
an emergency circumstances so our life
is
prepared in a way to expect
escalation or cases anytime
so as a father as a husband
from one hand and uh journalists on the
other hand
so uh of course it's it's difficult for
me as a father to keep
all the talking like my children uh come
especially uh with the huge blasts or
exclusions
that shake my house from time to time
this is uh
frankly this is the most difficult part
of the whole issue let's say being a
father
following with your children around the
clock even beyond my
sending been fixing me all the time to
ask me
about uh what is next what has been
hacked because these
explosions although sometimes they are a
bit far from
your your uh home but it shakes your
home because
they are carried off by uh fighting jets
sometimes
which which really shake the whole area
so on the outside
of the journalists we are prepared
for plan b as i said before plan b
plan c we have we have set lots of plans
because we expect
uh such escalation such development
anytime
which is which has happened in 2000 and
for
talking this is my personal experience
but still you know
most of the population of gaza is not
all the 2 million people and more
now um they uh they all depend
or live under emergency emergency plans
and emergency circumstances
so the population here are unemployed
two-thirds of the population live under
a poverty line and they depend on
uh international organization so
uh most gaza if not all
um live under special circumstances
based on or conditions based on
emergency plans
this is how life does life
look like in in the government living in
this
in this place uh under threat uh all the
time
i'm expecting escalation all the time so
you you don't live normal life all the
time you live with
always an emergency plan in your pocket
and
who has this plan is one of the luckiest
to say that because
as i told you the majority of the
population here
are unemployed and depend on food aids
and depend on eight organizations to
survive now
five days or six days people are indoors
no food supplies the crossings are
closed
um gaza is about
we can say now that the humanitarian and
extra humanitarian crisis
started but still about to because we
have the only
uh crossing commercial crossings that
supply gaza with the food
and with essential elements including
all the cooking garden soon
is closed for the fifth and the sixth
day the sea is completely
for the fishing is man now also uh
iron farmers cannot reach their farm
even to collect the harvest
of their from their farms to provide
also the market in gaza which are
which are running out of almost
everything
when it comes to uh to vegetables and
food and other essential elements
okay so it's a difficult lifestyle
emergency plan it is indeed well it's
good we have that emergency plan a plan
b
c or d in our back pocket at sapphire do
stay with us we'll get you back on the
line
shortly thank you very much that's al
jazeera suffereth alcahlut joining us on
the phone
he would have joined us from our live
point on top of the roof of our building
but that building as you will see
has just been bombed the al jazeera
offices the ap
offices and residential flats in the al
jalala
building have been destroyed al jazeera
is keeping broadcast signal back with
you after this
[Music]
each and every one of us have got a
responsibility
to change our personal space for the
better
this is the people's will and we